週末の間さ、あれ、なんか街とか行けたの?
そうなんだよ。なんか、メモはきっと信用されてたらしくて、全然自由にされた。
なんかね、一番最初の寄宿舎に入るときに、
週末、どのような日曜とか、お泊りでもなんでも、行ってもいい人の一応、リストをね、
ママたちがサインした、リストがあって、それを学校に見せるのね。
それで、出るたんびにどこに行きますか、名前書いて、その方にサインしてもらわなきゃいけないのよ。
それで、おじいちゃんも、子供の頃からのお友達がいらっしゃってね。
その人も、いつに行くような風に書いたのね、紙には。
まあまあ、全面書いたんだけど、おじいちゃんも、私に書いたんだけど。
それで、それで、そこの人、実際によく、あのー、日曜日のお昼ご飯に呼んでいただいて。
ねえけど、ご飯すんだら、もう、そっちのお子さんまで、全然ちっちゃくてね。
もう、ご飯すんだ、すぐに、2時とか2時半にはもう、帰っちゃって、それで、学校の夕方は、ほんと6時までに帰ればいいのね。
で、なんか、めめめめも、バカだから、そのまま、すぐ帰ってたわけが、そこに。
えええええええ。
帰っちゃって、ほんと、あのー、勉強の、あのー、なんだろう。
なんだろう、フリースタディーの時間なのね。
うんうんうん。
日曜日の、日本の、あの、そっきまでは。
え、どうやって帰ってたの?バス?
か、車?
車だよね、たぶん、え、帰って。
うんうん、あの、バス。
あん。
バス乗って帰ったり、半分歩いたり。
うんうんうん。
で、その、その、そのおじいちゃんのお友達っていうのは、あの、有名な、あの、ガイシャモンから、まっすぐ来てる、あの、サンザエンジェンって、大きな別に、すぐ近くだったんで。
へえ。
このお店とか、見たりして。
すごい。
何しても、なんか、疑われるようなことなくてね。
うんうん。
全然、ビルに歩き終わってたんで。
いいなー。
へえ。
だってね、結局、一人であんまり、どっか、何したらいいか、分かんないじゃない。それとか、歩き終わったお店見て、欲しいものあれば。
その、帰る制度の人だったら、そこには帰るとかしてたけど。
なんか。
でも、もちろん、あの、制服があるがんぼだからね。
普段、着るものとか、あんまり買わないで。
あ、そうだよね。
え、でも、パンとか美味しそう。
あ、おいしそう。
ほっ。
はい
どこだろう
そんな飴いらないよね
エブスタートの飴
おいしいけど
弱くじゃないの
なんか何かも
いらない気がする